la stabilité de la région du haut
karabagh est essentiel sur le pont
économique et stratégique c'est l'avis
de tallinn papazian a chargé de cours à
l'université d'aix marseille auteur de
l'ouvragé l'arménie à l'épreuve du feu
l'intérêt du président français se situe
à plusieurs niveaux d'abord il est
évident qu'une déstabilisation plus en
plus que ce qui est en cours aujourd'hui
au sud caucase est extrêmement
dangereuse pour l'europe le sud caucase
est tout de même en partenariat avec
l'europe par le partenariat oriental et
l'arménie fait partie de ce partenariat
un degré relativement poussée donc le la
france en tant que pays européens ne
veut pas d'une région déstabilisée dans
cet endroit là il y a évidemment des
liens d'amitié des liens commerciaux
avec l'arménie mais aussi avec
l'azerbaïdjan très très forte des liens
stratégiques puisqu'il ya des
entreprises françaises qui sont engagés
par la vente d'armements en azerbaïdjan
qu un rappelons le au passage et la
france est en excellente position pour
être médiatrice puisque comme je vous le
disais par le biais du groupe de minsk à
la fil des années construit une position
de relative impartialité
aujourd'hui la france dénonce clairement
que là tu as concours est une attaque
menée par l'azerbaïdjan et que la partie
arménienne ici est en position de
défense et que par ailleurs le rôle de
la turquie est délétère